[Music]
and uh what's up it's your boy Travis
Center here we'll be back
tough talks and yeah
it's time to go to work
the boys back home from the hospital
feel good
just resting I'll be back soon man
hey it's football at the end of the day
stuff like that happen so
yeah I'll be all right
but let's get into the show though I
appreciate everybody checking up on me
sending their prayers I'm good God got
me
yeah I see obj won my shirt
yeah
yeah I see LBJ wearing a shirt
that y'all never been out uh try not to
be on social media so much I'm just
home resting
still doing normal things yeah I'm just
holding wrestling
I'll be good appreciate y'all
and I'm being told Michael Parsons
Travis Hunter you don't deserve that
brother you way bigger than this moment
got respect about Travis he tried to get
back and fight and get back in that game
and that tells you a lot about the
competitor he is who he wants to be and
where he's going in life and try to keep
balling brother you doing something that
no one's seen at the college level to be
the efficient and as good as you are
both ways in college football yeah you
doing your thing brother keep going
um everyone's supporting you Travis
Hunter uh you don't deserve
appreciate it Mr Parsons I appreciate
that message man I know it's football
though at the end of the day stuff like
that's gonna happen so I just
stay home by me
hey
what you were supposed to do it's
football
something that's gonna happen sooner or
later we just gotta get up and fight
again that's what I try to do get up and
fight good thing the doctors thought
because if there was no Darkness there I
would have still been out that plan but
I don't think for everybody that helped
me that day
yeah you're working on your speedy
recovery
oh yeah Colorado State head coach Jay
Naval he added some feel to the fire at
the beginning of the week and Coach
Brown pulled up on the team with shades
it's pretty nice pretty much otherwise
he just trolling that's what we do
that's what was done strolling I mean
I don't get why other coaches talk about
this I mean we don't talk about nobody
else we just love to play the game we
play it our way and we do it our way you
know
when I actually trouble we don't try to
get into trouble we just go out there
and try to work man that's all you want
to do
what it's like that when I win a giraffe
bro
see it look
oh
that giraffe onesie now
let's drive onesie
catron got her she's he he was dropping
a new uh Shades line so I just helped
him with
with a lot
let's give him something
let's get him something these are those
shades
[Music]
thank you
I just want to see how y'all look here
oh they don't realize not only we gonna
kick their butts because it's personal
but it's gonna be business but it's also
a pleasure when I say business uh
blenders I do a live shades with
blenders this is one of the first lines
so they don't realize they just help me
with business
like 4.5 million in glasses and that's a
lot that's crazy though
glasses tough though I like the glasses
they look good you got a pair of y'all
got a pair of glasses do I play 2K yes
I'll play 2K you know we got uh also we
did have a lot of stars still up to the
game
uh Lil Wayne
it's my uncle to me
you always look out for me
how Lil Wayne pull up they got a lot of
stars pulled up all set grown The Rock
that was so many people that put up
I couldn't even I couldn't even remember
half of them but it but they pull up
there they don't try to bother us they
just let us go out there and play they
want to see the game Master P key Glock
see offset they don't try to bother they
let us go out there and play they're
coming to watch this like everybody else
that's called Larry
letting people know that they're
watching us a lot of people love
football they came out to watch us they
mean a lot to the team the team that
just it makes the team go out there and
want to perform how they how we should
uh perform so just having the
celebrities come around we like that
energy they come out and bring some good
energies for us and let us go ahead and
let us do our work and then we have fun
we have fun after the game
so I appreciate all the celebrities that
come out to see us it's a blessing for
them for us to get to see those people
oh yeah things did get heated in a
pre-game
it was it really nothing though it was
just talking
yeah that's what most teams gonna do a
lot of teams just want to talk
coaches talking
I don't get why the coaches talking but
come on now yes coaches in their team
talking man I don't really do nothing
but just because God never perform
I was supposed to foreign
[Music]
I'd like to fit appreciate it man
yeah
we talk too much
we don't talk bro you see other people
that talk to us we really don't care
what's going on man we're just gonna let
it play
oh who played tonight I need to pay
attention
see I always I'm gonna sleep all day and
a lot of y'all been asleep all day
I just woke up an hour ago though
I'm asleep all day
I ain't been having the energy to get up
and just
try to do a lot of things
it's trying to rest asleep
who played today though
what's the process for the speed of
recovery
hey just gotta rest the bodies do what
the body have to do
the body go to work the onesie heart
appreciate it man oh it's still the
Steelers and the Browns play and the
Saints and the Panthers play oh
I got to see that I don't know who I
don't got no
it's still this around since the
Panthers
I don't know it's gonna be a good game
for all those teams I'm gonna watch them
though
that's the football there
also the game disc got off great when
shallow picked the uh got to pick six I
was happy for him
hey man he watched a lot of film he's
been telling everybody he was going to
jump their route as soon as he came he
jumped it did what he said he was going
to do didn't hesitate was in the right
place he tried to host that but he
realized the dude was coming to get him
so he put the ball down and just got to
go and I was so happy but I was like the
third person fourth person there
I was running I'll have to go catch that
boy I was so happy for him Miss I love
our roommates at the teen Hotel so we we
always talking before the game we
switched beds because last game we
didn't have a good game so we switched
that this this uh this game he had a
good game he got a six so I think we're
gonna do that for now
he believes in himself watched film and
I was just happy we got the first Pick 6
17. I was super proud of him man that's
my boy man he the first person to call
me after the game
yeah man solo just
this
we always with each other
so I was happy he did what he was
supposed to do he have to team mouth got
a forceful and also I was happy for him
no
it's not really a ranking but it's a fun
but I'm the first kid
I'm number one
um she came in and gave me the biggest
hug and kiss and appreciation to your
daddy that she could ever give me at the
end of the game so that was great in
juniors football and what he does on
social media is is
fascinating so it's tough my kids
rankings are tough It's a serious run
right now
it really is it's a serious ride
like you love all of them the same and
you don't
well I seen that clip of Shiloh uh I
forgot what it was called but it was so
funny
so I think it was uh
close Prime Playbook when it was little
where Shiloh was so funny when he was
little bro he's always been a
always been a family comedian man it was
funny
things got tough in this I sure don't
want pretty mode on them
now I was in a I was in the hospital
watching a game like this couldn't watch
it for real I was so scared at the end
yeah I went to turn it up
I mean we do these we do these drills in
practice
I mean look what happened it happens in
the game and we go down and do what we
were supposed to do
that's crazy I already knew if he was
going to school in this yard when I was
watching I was like well we got a
two-point play and this this nothing my
coach prom situation so I know we're
gonna make the best decision get down
get out of bounds get the ball back to
the ref Tempo help us out a lot because
that's what happened in this moment
uh Temple got out of now it's perfect
everything was one that's playing man
it's God's plan
you know exactly what he was doing he
helped us all with this
touchdown Jimmy
that's what we're supposed to do
Tempo play helped us on
Italian
98 98 yards
two minute drill and Coach prompted us
through those situations so much and
forward countless so much during the
week it's like it's just come natural to
us now that we already know what's going
on
so we don't shake up in those pressure
moments We rise in depression moments
and we like to be we like to pressure on
this because we get to show everybody
what we're about and that post game
interview From Shadows cold cold talking
about Brady mode
what was your message to your teammates
when you guys took over the ball of the
two
other two our last thing was birdie mode
that's it simple Brady mode Freddy mode
that's it you left too much time out
there
he's been a mentor of yours
yeah of course yeah we talked we talk
after every game I'm sure he's gonna
text me in a second but that's how I was
thinking it's Brady mode if he could do
it I know I could do it in you know we
just alike what was your message
yeah man that's how I felt on KTCU when
they left us too much Tom went down to
scrape
on on then the enforcement too it's like
yeah then that was too much time
okay then the ball here man did his
thing scored now we stopped him on
defense I was like yeah they they messed
up and they left us too much time
can't leave us too much time we're gonna
find a way every time and get out of
there and get the win
the monkey came in glitch
that was that was good he came in a
clutch
I was happy
oh my god did you see that game
prime time
he was decided for us that he came out
though he came modern fall Camp gave us
a few words
I see why he's so proud man he's been
with us
he never doubted us we knew we was gonna
have a good team
so it's about man people that was around
before then
it's like
so we got a blur time for some Bean tops
and how we get you know how I go let's
get right into it
first play
blue
now that's a blur for real who he snag
that I thought that was a pick for Shout
oh my God he took that off his head
no way he just did that
oh no way
yeah buddy you just got blue
oh he definitely could snap that up this
blur I'm gonna go get that one I'll
catch right that boy
um
T-Mac boy team Matt go crazy
she might go crazy boy
team man come crazy that's a nice catch
team at that's a blue only here both of
them
no cap
Little D where you at Little D
hey I seen that one
that's a nice catch
I'm working cash man
I've seen this play though that's a nice
catch you definitely gotta don't snagger
Rooney's
you put the food to the whole
organization
yeah team act like that for real she
might go crazy LOL you got smoke yes but
I definitely got smacked
but it was funny bro at the worst not
when it happened though I could laugh
when it happened
yeah I definitely got smacked though
yeah I've been laughing at all all day
bro this is funny to me bro I definitely
got smacked up that boy called me now
it's time for overreaction and not
overreaction let's get right into it man
he comes in the league and he does what
he does in at the college level he's a
top five receiver and he's a top five
Corner four years later the first three
to four hundred million dollar players
yeah
in the league and he does what he does
in at the college level
and he's a top five corner
not overreaction hey I believe anything
can happen
just gotta believe in God man God is the
key
believing God it could happen you never
know
I believe in God though like they said
it could happen
you know it's gonna stay blessed up stay
prayed up and I'll hoping it's gonna
happen
they're not different a giraffe costume
yeah they smacked me into this night
uh what do we got next oh shallow that's
the best coach
you know we're getting it working 21
days
to do
it's funny too
baby
[Music]
it's not a reaction man that's close
from precious by far by far nobody else
can do like shallow
oh I seen this play I was watching it I
was watching the Missouri six million I
feel about
the best player of the weekend
no I don't think so
I don't think it was the best play but
hey it was nice though
no I can't do no close Chrome impression
now it was a nice player though I seen
that I was watching it because you know
uh Sam that was no quarterback in
high school so I'll be watching all the
Missouri games
so but it's my dog
yeah
country guy honey yes sir definitely did
definitely got your boy sound good
though best football
clean or not it's all football man
solo it's not funny bro I'm gonna have
me rolling Alabama deserves to not be in
the top 10 for the first time since
2015.
hey
oh no a lot of overreaction I guess I
don't like talking about the teeth I
ain't got nothing to do with me
I don't know man I don't know
man I would like to judge other teams
bro
[Music]
yeah it is bro
it's not old reaction bro
now those reactions bro they sleeping on
my Stitch ones and I got a giraffe ones
you know I'm gonna have a different one
on next week
yeah bro stop stop sleeping on my one
I'm the ones you got
yeah bro
the Stitch onesie slap on man sleeping
on my Stitch ones
all right now we got Hollywood loaded
candidates right now for me number four
markipedics
hey he been balling man I'm going crazy
number three Caleb Williams
like I said bro all these boys on his
husband loading listen man they've been
balling can't get any better any better
than these people right here man they're
involving since week one uh number two
shador
since week one
this is crazy but he's still been to the
same numbers still figuring out a way to
get the dub it's crazy and we not
playing no no bad teams we find them
away every time to get a dub
that's crazy number one
of course I'm gonna put myself again
even though I'm out
hey when I come back I got waterproof it
ain't doing nothing but adding more feel
to the fryer
and I know when I come back it's over
with I'm just gonna be in dominate mode
everybody gotta get it
it's time to go to work in this
time to put everything out there
so let me know just gotta go out there
man
position
but I'd rather go into moreover with a
husband
both I can get both of them
you're playing both at the next level
yes I'm gonna try to play both at the
next level that's what I want to do man
that is my gold
you still playing 2K yes I might get on
Twitch later
play 2km I don't know though I might go
upstairs and get some more rice I've
been in uh
I don't want to talk to anybody
this man in the bed laying down sleeping
for real trying to get away from
everything I can you still gotta talk
about the boys Road
test and organ
I just wish I could be out there with my
boys
heartbreaking that I can't
it's all good though
I feel like we just got to be more
focused this week
you got to be more focused
focus is key locked in is key everybody
gotta do their job we got to get the job
done no matter what if I'm in or if I'm
out we got to get the job done no matter
what people don't care the next team
don't care that I'm not there so we just
got to go in there get the job done
that's that's what I that's what I
that's what I have for the team I just
wanted to go out there get a job done
stay true to yourself go out there and
show the world that just cause one
prayer down doesn't mean the whole team
is down guard then perform how to put
how they supposed to perform are they
locked in ready to go get the last game
behind them already get the corrections
right
going this game ready to play understand
the assignment get the assignment done
yeah it's gonna be a tough game but we
just got to go out there and bar lobster
no matter what's going on and that's a
half of my team I just want to go out
there before
I'll be watching trust me it's hard to
watch who you have no control but hey
I'll be watching
I'm gonna find the channel and I'm gonna
be sitting down watching the game
no matter what
Marco Martinez potato Wheels fall off
and when the wheels fall off I'm still
gonna be rocking with them I want the
boys will be locking lock in get this
stuff
come back home so we can celebrate
yeah
hey man I appreciate y'all tuning there
until I talk it's your boy chocolate
Center
appreciate y'all sending prayers
I'll be back soon
we're gonna be back on here next Monday
recap it again recap of the weekend you
know we get I love everybody
appreciate y'all for being here with
your support Travel Center with tough
talk so we out
[Music]